thank you all for having me and it's so
awesome to see so many of you at 9:00
a.m. in the morning to discuss metrics
so let's hope we keep you engaged till
the end of the session so how do we
think about what metrics to track and
our advisors find out which business
model you fit in you know the most
common thing people do is which industry
vertical are you in are you healthcare
are you
biotech or I you enterprise but that's
not really the best way to think of
metrics the best way to think of metrics
is how do you plan to charge your users
which is the business model and which of
these business models do you fit in so
roughly there are nine business models I
mean I've I would say 99% of you should
fit into one of these categories if you
don't you're probably building something
that's incredibly hard which is what we
call moonshot so let I walk you through
for the rest of the presentation on each
business model and what three or four
metrics you need to track beyond three
to four honestly at this stage is an
overkill so these are the things that
would matter so what is an enterprise
business model this is a company that
sells software or services to a large
enterprise pretty simple there if you
startups do that so I would expand to
launch something from day one that sells
to say Facebook or Google or Apple or
any of them but if you are one of those
companies examples are like dark darker
cloud or fire I even in the YC portfolio
there are very few that did that from
day one but if you're one of them that
sells to large enterprises you would
characterize yourself in this category
and the large enterprises tend to work
in terms of contracts so your business
model will come in to three things which
are the three metrics you track which is
bookings so if you're working with say
Facebook they'd say hey you're gonna
help us hire X engineers we'd like to
sign a hundred thousand dollar contract
for next year so that's why you'd say
what is my booking what's the total
number of unique customers I have and
what's revenue
the difference between booking and
revenue is Facebook might sign a
contract ahead of time would tell you at
the start of the year that it's a
hundred thousand Forex hires over the
year that doesn't mean you recognize
revenue straight away you recognize
revenue only when you have delivered the
service either you've placed all the
hires that you said in your contract or
if it's an annual contract you just
divide it monthly so the common mistakes
we see founders do is confusing bookings
and revenue you know they would have
signed contracts but they haven't
delivered anything this contract hasn't
even kicked in but they're already
reporting it as revenue that's not true
because you haven't delivered service so
therefore it's not revenue and so you
should hold yourself accountable for
that like the company is not generating
revenue the second common mistake which
is probably more relevant at the stage
that you're in is you know Facebook
might have verbally told you I will
consider a 100k contract you know for
that 100k it's not a big deal for a lot
of you it's a really big deal that's
neither booking nor revenue because it's
a verbal offer so the other even if you
even if they sign a letter of intent it
means nothing so you really have to have
the contract written down sign for it to
be bookings and for revenue only when
you start delivering it the second
business model is SAS which is probably
where most of you fit in especially if
you're in b2b or you know servicing to
other companies you're all probably
thinking of SAS model it's a very
prominent model these days you know you
see a number all these sub YC startup
segments iron clad San Burt they all
started with SAS model right from day
one SAS is software as a service in
terms of business model it's really
subscription business you charge
something monthly for a software that
you provide so what are the four metric
key metrics you would want to track well
if it's subscription by definition that
revenue is recurring right which means
if you hopefully have built something
that people really like they'll continue
to use it and they pay you every month
so that's why you track em are are at
the highest level that is monthly
recurring revenue how much are you
making monthly and what did the
customers come at
ARR is annual recurring revenue because
of this face you're really growing fast
you may be growing 30% week of a week or
40% week over week so it's helpful to
track your annual recurring revenue as
literally run rate so if this month you
made thirty thousand and I'm RR and if
it's truly recurring you should expect
that your annual recurring is twelve
times that so it's just a good metric to
use internally as well because it helps
show the pace rather than just looking
at absolute the third thing you should
pay attention to is chart so when you
launch there will be few users who are
early adopters that use it but you
really should be paying attention to if
they stop using it right and if you're a
subscription business the chances are
you probably make five thousand to ten
thousand dollars a month from two or
three customers or maybe even ten so
losing a customer means real impact on
your revenue and so this is why we we
recommend measuring something called
gross mrl churn which is how they at the
start of the month you expected your
monthly recurring revenue to be ten
thousand but one customer churn and they
were paying three thousand then that's
your gross churn 3000 by ten thousand so
don't blend it because you're obviously
acquiring new users and if you measure
blended you numbers still look great
right because you're growing a lot but
you're not paying attention to users
that you're losing and it's really
important to learn from users you're
losing which is why we ask you to
measure the churn paid kak this comes in
a little later hopefully almost all of
you are acquiring users organically
I wouldn't recommend doing any paid
acquisition at the stage but if you do
start doing some experiments where you
say hey I'm gonna do a little bit of
paid marketing or advertising to get a
few customers then you should measure
what was the cost to get that user
through paid mechanism so which is
literally saying if I spent $10,000 on
Facebook or any other channel that you
used and you got five customers from
that channel how much did you pay for
that common mistakes
two really common mistakes and this
happens again and again even spite of
like highlighting it which is ARR
literally stands for annual recurring
recurring is the most important word
revenue if you don't have a recurring
business which is you don't chat
subscription your customers are not
committing to 12 months of payment you
don't have a recurring round in your
business so internally if you start
calling it ARR everyone thinks oh it's
rep you know it's repeat business it's
not because you have to go back and
acquire them each month or you have to
have you know you have to work with your
customers to make sure they pay every
month so the most common mistake is
people instead of saying annual run rate
which actually is not very useful even
to gauge your business if you use ARR be
absolutely sure you have a recurring
revenue and the second mistake people
make is when their what they would say
oh yeah it's recurring revenue but
actually the customer would have
committed to only one-time payment or
you know you may have done a consulting
project and it's not really clear
whether they're gonna pay second month
or third month but they would still
include it as a matter you know it's not
make sure you're including only what's
truly recurring where the customer has
said I'm signed up for a 12 month or a
six month annual plan and this is what
I'm being is subscription this is
probably more relevant for consumer
businesses so if you Dollar Shave Club
blue apron applet take there are lots of
companies especially subscription as a
service is becoming so popular in
consumer right now it's very similar to
SAS but it has a slight nuance so
similar to SAS because you have M RR
which is recurring right you may have
signed up a Netflix annual subscription
it's recurring it's monthly recurring
the two differences is instead of
looking at a RR or any of that we
actually say measure your monthly growth
and unit churn not dollar chart why is
that because if you're selling to
companies usually your subscription is
more value right it's like they're
paying two thousand five thousand
dollars
there if you lose a customer the impact
on revenue is a lot so you should really
look at revenue churn if you look at
Netflix everybody pays 7 or 10 dollars
per month so it's about volume of
customers which is why we say pay
attention to growth because you need to
make sure that the number of users using
Netflix continues to increase and you
measure unit churn not necess to
customer who's paying $10 that's $10 but
if you lost thousand customers paying
$10 each that's significant right so
which is why we say measure gross unit
churn was as if you're a SAS business
selling to companies measure revenue
churn and paid kak is very similar like
the last time but just make sure if
you're spending paid marketing measure
the cost associated with acquiring those
users don't do it on a blended basis so
when you are at this stage you will tend
to grow in spikes so this month you may
grow 80% next month you would grow 10%
next month you may grow another 90%
right that's natural because you're
learning you're iterating and you're
trying to figure out you know what
really resonates with the user so what's
really important is to make sure that
since launch since the month you started
acquiring users you measure compounded
monthly growth rate so which is let the
current month divided by the first month
and you know decrease that growth rate
proportionately for the number of months
since launched what founders often do is
mistake is they would just do the
average so they do 90 percent this month
plus 10% second month plus 80% third man
what happens with averages it makes your
growth look good because you had some
spikes you want to be true to yourself
because these won't be problems when you
are two or three people team you know
but hopefully you all will scale and
we'll start hitting 10 people team and
then when you set goals someone will be
very happy that it's 50% growth rate but
that's because you're measuring growth
wrong the next is transactional
businesses this is probably more new new
in the sense that's happened in the last
eight to ten years and again you see
that with stripe PayPal coinbase Brax a
lot of FinTech
companies especially fall in this
category so what is a transactional
company which is if you're in the safe
in tech or payment space you probably
process a lot of payments volume right
let's take stripe for example they power
the payments for more startups and so
every startups payment volume goes to
stripe that's the transactional business
but stripe collects a fee for the
transactions so if you're a type of
business that processes someone else
payments volume then you should put
yourself in the transactional bucket so
the gross transaction volume is the tpv
or the total payments volume that flows
through the platform so stripe had 30
customers at your stage and all 30
customers were processing say 100
million and tpv but it all went through
stripe that's TBD but that's not revenue
revenue is what goes to your bank
account so that's your cut which is why
it's called net revenue so the portion
of transaction volume that you make so
stripe would say hey I charge two and a
half percent for the payment volume that
flows through my platform the two and a
half percent is the net revenue that
they take if you're in the transactional
business it's very common that you'll
have lots of customers right so within a
year of launch you could even have
thousand two thousand customers then the
important metric to track has user
retention because you want to make sure
that six months after they're using you
or twelve months after they've started
using you hopefully they're still using
you why because you are powering their
platform unless you've gone out of
unless they've gone out of business
there should be no reason they're not
using your platform how are they doing
business like imagine if someone stopped
using stripe well are they out of
business or who is processing their
payments so that's why it's really
important to measure your cohort
retention on a monthly basis if you're a
transaction business and paid calc is
very similar to what you know in all
cases it's the same thing just natural
different paid channels but again as I
said hopefully none of you are doing
paid marketing so what is the common
mistake here
confusing gross transaction volume to
net revenue as I said like if you are
processing
million in transaction volume that's not
net revenue that's not the cash that
hits your bank two and a half percent of
the hundred million hits your bank
that's a much smaller number so you
should really make sure what you called
revenue was this transaction volume and
I've often seen founders here sometime
come up with like oh but I process the
volume that's my revenue no excuses net
revenue is literally the cash you make
in the bank and then user retention is a
cohort metric it's not one number it's
not like oh I retain 30% of my users
that means nothing to us right even for
you it should not because if it's if
you're powering payments you should say
well 40% of my customers have used it
consistently for the 12 months since
they joined us well that's a better
metric next is marketplace again this is
more simple it looks like transaction
but it's different it's typically used
by consumer companies so Airbnb eBay are
all good examples of marketplace
what's the marketplace you have two
sites so in Airbnb you have hosts and
guests guests go to the platform select
a room booked it the host is happy
that's a marketplace so what are the
three or four metrics that matter here
gmv right so when the guest books the
platinum room you know the host might
say it's $100 per night and sure the
$100 per night say they say - two nights
it's $200 that $200 is gmv that
everybody can record but that's not net
revenue because air B&B doesn't make the
full $200 everybody probably makes 12%
of that right so 12% of that $200 is
what you would classify as net revenue -
other metrics again similar to the other
morals that we talked about you wanna
track here is compounded monthly growth
rate if you see this is a more important
metric for consumer businesses right
because volume of consumers matter and
therefore it's really important to track
your monthly growth rate in a compounded
way so you can keep yourself honest how
you're growing and similarly when it
comes to consumer businesses you should
pay an attention to user retention not
necessarily dollar attention because
volume of users matter so here you would
say what percentage of customers came
back to Airbnb or Airbnb retained you
know 6 months or 12 months from now now
in Airbnb skates how often do people
travel does anyone want to take a guess
was that once a year very good so how
should they track how when should they
be happy when should they be sad once a
year yes so if you imagine when
everybody was going through YC and they
could see their cohort repetition once a
year how are you gonna know you're doing
a good building a good business there to
wait 12 months will you wait 12 months
to check whether your customers are
coming back no so this is what you have
to get creative and the way to get
creative is reflect on your user
behavior so if you're going to book
something hopefully someone who's
troweling is not booking the day before
they're traveling they start doing
research six months before and so Airbnb
studied that and so what they would
track is if you as users came back to at
least search for a city or a booking six
months so you in this stage of your
startup what's most important is to
really be truthful and honest about how
you want the users to behave and come up
with those retention metrics to measure
if your business is really healthy and
are you seeing what you want to see from
your users so what's the common mistake
here this was especially acute for
Airbnb because they didn't pay anything
for demand-side right they had a
brilliant value proposition there were
really good designers very good
storytellers demand they didn't pay
anything but they had to pay to acquire
hosts because guess what no one was
ready to let their homes to strangers so
they had to work hard which was you know
they had to put you know advertising
around events so they had to spend a few
dollars on acquiring hosts pretty much
very early on so the number one mistake
founders tend to do here is you know
you're acquiring a bunch of users
organically and some users through paid
and you'll blend everything you'll say I
acquired hundred users this month and so
my CAC was 12 but what had happened was
if you truly measured who you acquired
from paid advertising channel it could
be as high as 70 and so you have to ask
yourself is it sustainable is it is are
you really seeing the ROI in paid
channels so if you are in an unusual
situation like Airbnb where your
business frequency is not very high
because people use once a year and you
have to pay the choir host it's really
important to pay attention to where your
money is going and whether you're
getting a good ROI from that ecommerce
ecommerce is you know literally you have
certain goods to sell you're selling
them online people are ordering it
Molly Parker bonobos minibox a lot of
them you know that's what we would
characterize as e-commerce which is you
make the products or source the products
but ultimately it's your brand and
someone's coming to the brand to
purchase it so here again it's a
consumer business you track monthly
revenue you notice there's no recurring
no subscription it's just revenue
because people might buy a product this
Monday may not buy it next month right
so it's monthly revenue because it's
consumer business again very important
to track a component monthly growth rate
for e-commerce even from day one it's
important to track your gross margin
because you either make the good or
you're sourcing it and branding it under
your name so it's important to
understand what it takes what is your
cost to get the good so that you're
making some profit on a per product
basis and it's more important for
ecommerce because you it's not a
recurring business right so you have to
make sure that you're able to make money
on a per transaction braces so which is
why gross margin is important to track
paid kak very similar to all the other
examples common mistake gross profit for
e-commerce is not accounting for all
costs now Amazon does a great job of
this and people often say oh yeah they
have very thin margins but actually it's
net margin after all costs and so if
high-volume net margin times high-volume
is a pretty good Aveda business which
you can use to find out for future
investments so the common mistake we see
here is an e-commerce as people would
say oh say I bought you know a clip and
we know the cost of the clip is $10 they
wouldn't include shipping cost
they wouldn't include customer
processing costs they wouldn't include
payment processing costs all that is
important because if you don't include
those cost you're probably pricing it
wrong and so it's so important that
you're pricing it wrong pretty much from
first transaction advertising we see far
fewer companies in the advertising space
these days but if you happen to be in
that space then you know the common
companies that are analogues for you are
snapchat Twitter reddit
they all have you know huge social
network that come to their site for
different reasons but the primary
monetization model is advertisers
advertise there and companies make money
from advertisers so at this stage
because you probably will never be
monetizing if you're in that vert icing
business it's all about the users and so
when it comes to users there are really
only three things that matter daily
active monthly active percent logged in
so who are the users who use your app
daily monthly active who use it monthly
and then percent logged in as actively
logged in using a username and password
the common mistake and I'll give many
examples of this not defining what
active means so there was the company I
think three or four years ago that
reported a daily active user metric and
I remember asking them what is active
and you know I had some sense of like
maybe for somebody who have read engaged
whatever and this founder answered well
those are the emails I sent that's not
active you know active again it goes
back to the Airbnb example you should
define what you want your users to
behave like when using your app so if
you're building a news app does it mean
reading conscious active does it mean
commenting councils active
you should define that really well and
so if you don't define that you could be
building something that has no
stickiness and probably you know you're
gonna have users that are winding down
pretty quickly and it's not worth it
right so make sure you really define
what activists and hold yourselves to
that metric
the other one is hardware it's again
very similar to ecommerce because at the
end of the day they're selling a device
so if your Fitbit group Pro Xiaomi you
know we'd say you're in the heart that
bucket as you can see it's very
similarly comments where you look at
monthly revenue component monthly growth
rate you look at gross margin and really
carefully hopefully you're making profit
from day one and then paid kak okay so
those are the nine business models and
one last thing I'd leave you with before
I open it up to questions as common
mistakes so common mistakes is you've
heard this and you've probably read this
in so many blogs charges that look up
into the right are brilliant well but
cumulative charts are always up into the
right do not have any comment there is
no rationale in the world to have a
cumulative charge so I I don't know a
single company at scale that shows a
cumulative charge so do not take a
cumulative chart second thing I've seen
is not labeling y-axis like as I said
you're going to scale even if you hit
five or seven users you know if you're
if you don't know what the y-axis label
is and if the charts look like straight
vertical bars it means nothing
third is changing Y axis scale this is
something I never understood but quite a
few of them do it which is you know x
axis starts at zero and y axis starts at
say 50 those things don't really show
how well you're growing show your
problems by the way no YC startup had a
charge straight up into the right no one
did
even the most successful companies
didn't either so I think the most
important thing is to really be honest
measure and fix things right it's okay
to go down sometimes and also usually we
say don't show only percentage charts
it's very important that whatever you're
measuring whether it's gross revenue
churn monthly growth be clear about the
absolute number and the percentage is
relative to the absolute number
we also have you know done detailed post
on metrics while I was at a 16 Z so
having two links there if anyone wants
to look at it but at your stage only
three or four metrics matter if anything
you took from here hopefully you fit
into one of these nine business models
you can start with two or three of these
metrics for each business model and that
itself would be a great head start for
all of you thank you yeah so the
question is can we map bookings to
accrual accounting right yeah I think
that's not I mean the purpose of
tracking bookings versus revenue is not
from an accounting standpoint it's from
how do you gauge your business meaning
bookings as future revenue right so all
that all you're saying is I have signed
a contract four hundred thousand dollars
I am NOT ready to launch for them until
two months from now but you know that
it's future bookings because it's all
signed and the customer has committed to
working with you so you say it's hundred
K and then but you're not starting to
deliver service until two months from
now which means you can't recognize
revenue so it's only a measure to manage
your business internally so you know
that this is coming in the pipeline this
is where my team's resources is going to
go but if I want to hit the goal of 200
K by the end of the year how should I
you know maybe you need to go find one
more customer or accelerate launching
your service which is most likely the
case in your you know in the face that
you are in which is why am i reading two
months to launch this what can I do to
launch it tomorrow
we can pick from a couple of different
things these nine verticals in business
model is there something that you're
recommending for a community business to
attract early on before you decide
business level I think that the question
was really what should we track for
community business
I put community business whether your
business model is advertising or not in
that category so really what you should
be tracking is Jeff define who your
active user is and what you want that
user to do so daily active users and
monthly active and track weekly how
they're doing
[Music]
yeah um you know most businesses evolved
to different business models over time
right what's most important is what is
your short-term focus so if your
short-term is like for the next year or
two which is about finding product
market fit in your transactional
business then that's the that's the area
you want to start with
[Music]
[Music]
yes absolutely so the question was what
should we talk to for investors at this
stage honestly the bet is only on two or
three things which is you as the founder
what unique insight do you have that
you're building this and can this be a
big company that's it and so don't over
complicate this yeah so great question
about excite again as I said it's very
easy to get caught up in what do
investors want to see but the most
important thing is you know more about
the business than anyone and so it's
about what should you track to make sure
your business is healthy so the two
things as founders you should track very
early on is burn right because you're
spending cash so you should always know
don't run out of money so makes there's
no excuse for running out of money so
make sure you do your P&L thoroughly so
that you're tracking your burn and you
know that there's enough money in the
bank to at least operate the company for
another six to nine months to is if
we're related to expenses it's the gross
margin especially if you're in business
categories that are ecommerce or
consumer related then they do pay
attention it's important for founders to
pay attention to gross margin which is
on a poor transaction basis am i making
money or not because if net you're not
making money then it's a you know do you
have line of sight when you would make
money because if you don't then you
should really question you know is there
a business to be built but I'd suspect
it's quite early right not which is why
I say focus on getting the users and how
do you monetize that's the first step
and for business this has a model of
kind of like say ancestry.com where
people sign up they get a report and
they may want to come back later if
there's no purchase yeah I think you
should do both but I would record
revenue it's just their Avenue for that
month because it was purchased only for
that month and then you just figure out
like how Airbnb did which is what's the
behavior you expect do they do you
expect them to come back once a year if
so are they and what percentage of them
are coming back yeah I'll go to this
site
[Music]
yeah
so great question and this is why I
brought up the Airbnb host example right
the only thing that I would say that's
probably most important is to measure
the paid acquisition cost of bringing
that supplier in because you know in
most marketplaces it's actually really
hard to get the demand side which is the
users right and if you get enough
business for the supply the supply will
stay and especially at this point again
if you were three years out and you have
scaled and you are at like 20 30 million
GMB the answer to your question is
different at this point it's about how
do I get both sides organically as far
as possible if you have to spend on the
supply side for a little bit okay but
try experiments every now and then but
when you're trying experiment the most
important thing to measure is what's
your paid acquisition cost because
hopefully it's not so much that you're
born goes out of whack so that those are
the two that really
like some noodles so what's the
recommendation like break down the small
teams of individuals in theater price in
given and enterprise businesses you
can't really sell to Facebook from day
one how should we focus about the
go-to-market should we just go to small
teams you almost always start with small
teams or a pilot right so when companies
do you know focus on enterprise you
usually start with a pilot but the pilot
could be something like it's a six-month
pilot or it could be a three-month pilot
in those cases you don't report them as
bookings or revenue you just say it's a
pilot at the end of the pilot we visit
whether we can get a contract and the
face that you're in usually it you'll
have only one or two customers over the
course of 12 to 24 months that's okay
because the ACV if it works are the
contract annual contract would be really
huge and that's expected it's the good
acquisition customer cost is zero so let
me just say that that's the best
customer acquisition costs especially at
this stage because if you have built
something that people really want you
will get it without spending much right
so at this stage it's only zero as you
scale there's obviously room it's not
necessarily it's the correct answer is
not an absolute dollar number the way
you look at it is you compare your
acquisition costs to the lifetime value
of the customer so if you had the
customer for one year in every in this
case for example if everybody says yeah
you know this customer booked twice with
me and if they do that every year I make
hundred dollars from them then you say I
can you know you should have a 5x gap so
you at you're willing to spend $20 to
acquire but at this stage the answer is
zero
[Applause]
you